[Music]
second of two Killian award lectures to
be presented by Institute professor
Mildred Spivak dresselhaus let me simply
remind you that the Killian award is the
highest honor the faculty can bestow on
a colleague as a recognition of quote
extraordinary professional
accomplishments and to provide through
the lectures a means for the
communication of these accomplishments
to the faculty students other members of
the MIT community and to the general
public thus also in a quote honoring the
contributions made by dr. Killian to the
intellectual life of the Institute to
give millie as much time as possible
I'll say no more about her extraordinary
accomplishment still get up yet Pelle
and her multifaceted contributions to
MIT but we'll simply introduce her
second lecture in a series the overall
series is called
new materials through science and new
science through materials the first
lecture was entitled adventures in
carbon research and it was an adventure
and I knowing nothing about physics
enjoyed the adventure very much I'm
looking forward to date today's lecture
as I'm sure you are it's entitled new
materials and new science by
intercalation million dresselhaus
looks as if i frightened quite a few
people since the last lecture I hope
those that that are here will enjoy what
I have to say since the last lecture I
had a the nicest little note from dr.
Killian whom you know is in the
infirmary ad thank God that we have high
tech high tech brought the lecture to
him in the hot in the infirmary and he
was able to watch all of this on his
screen he particularly appreciated the
remarks I made about mrs. Killian and
her interest in women in science and our
women students and faculty and their
activities and as I mentioned in the
first lecture I was dedicating the
lecture series to mrs. Killian to her
memory in the morning news today I heard
about this week being national science
and engineering week and it seemed that
this was a very fitting week to have the
Killian lectures as a contribution of
MIT to the public understanding of
science as many of you know I have
strong feelings that scientific and
technological organizations should give
effort to the public understanding of
science and and also that the faculty
should participate in these kinds of
things so I'm very happy that this
happens to be the week for it science
and technology well in my first lecture
I spoke about adventures and I guess
that the view graphs are not so visible
with the large amount of lighting in the
front maybe that that's that's very much
improved the first lecture I devoted
myself to talking about some of my
adventures and carbon research and today
I'd like to talk about some
being different on new materials and new
science through intercalation this is
really a talk maybe the first one was
also but this is a talk in material
science my own introduction to this
notion of new materials through science
and new science through materials came
through professor Arthur fund Hipple
professor von Hippel was the dominant
figure in the Department of Electrical
Engineering and computer science for a
very very long time in the area of
Materials Research and he had some
notions that I support 100% what he
thought was that through science we
could learn about the properties of
materials and make meant and generate
materials that would have properties
that we would like them to have so this
is the kind of materials engineering and
I it could be said that Professor von
Hippel is the father of our modern
notion of materials engineering now to
make all of this happen
to have people working on science of new
materials you have to have a
collaborative effort between physicists
who are doing physics on new materials
chemists who make the new materials and
and material sciences scientists who
worry about the processing of materials
and in his laboratory at MIT we had a
very nice blend mixture of people
working on all aspects of the same
materials to make things as a whole
beyond what individuals could do by
themselves now that was my inspiration
the implementation came through a
different route through Ted jabal who at
that who at the time that he inspired me
was a member of the technical staff at
the Bell Laboratories and in 1965 he and
a group of co-workers discovered super
conduct
in intercalation compounds and I was at
that time already known as an expert on
the electronic properties of graphite
and he contacted me very soon after this
discovery to say gee we found the most
interesting thing we take carbon in the
form of graphite and we add to the
carbon alkali metals potassium rubidium
and cesium and lo and behold we get
something that's superconducting when we
know darn well that none of the
constituents that we put in there are
superconducting by themselves this is a
very interesting phenomenon perhaps you
could do some of these high field
magneto reflection experiments and learn
something about what happens to the
modification of the band structure of
graphite that promotes superconductivity
well the boundary conditions for doing
those experiments were very unfavorable
at that time and we thought about this
experiment for a few years but nothing
much happened in the way of
implementation until a paper was
published in 1971 in European Journal it
was a very very short paper but what it
showed is that you could see quantum
oscillations in intercalation compounds
well what Ted jabal did for me if he
alerted me to the field of intercalation
compounds and I started sort of
following the literature and sort of on
the back burner we weren't really doing
anything actively but when this paper
came along I knew we should get into the
business and do something serious and it
was in this way that I got into the
study of new materials so what is an
intercalation compound anyway and why
why do we care about them well in
intercalation compound is formed by the
introduction of entire layers of guest
species into a host material suppose the
host material is graphite is in our case
here and we introduce layers of some
foreign species like an alkali metal
what are the requirements for this to
happen for one thing we it's necessary
for the host material to have extremely
strong bonding so when the guest species
is introduced it doesn't mess up the
layers of the host material and of
course that satisfy the graphite and the
inter planar binding is very weak so
it's that it's easy to introduce whole
layers of foreign species into the host
material now there are in fact a number
of different host materials that will
work graphite is only one of them
transition metal dye chalcogen I'd say
you can have their semiconductors you
can have metals that whole class of
materials will accommodate interpolation
as many other materials so there is a
whole bunch of host materials and there
are also a whole bunch of inter colons
that could be put into each of them now
the connection between this and
materials engineering is clear because
by selectively selecting what you put
into the host material you can change
say the transport properties you can
take a material that say the transition
metal guy chalcogen i'ts semiconductor
introduce materials into between the
layers
and make the whole system conducting or
in the case of graphite you could
increase the conductivity by more than
an order of magnitude or you can put in
a magnetic species taking the host
material that was not magnetic at all
and make it magnetic or introduce in the
layers of superconducting elements and
make the material superconducting etc so
there is a whole variety of things that
can be put in and that gives you an
opportunity to tailor the graphite to
make layered materials and isotropic
materials with diverse properties now
why is graphite so interesting why
graphite rather than the other host
materials well for a physicist the main
attraction of graphite is symmetry that
when you introduce the intercalate into
graphite it goes in into the graphite in
an ordered way in the following sense
that the separation between sequential
layers of the intercalation here as the
red dashed lines the spacing between
these is the fixed number of graphite
layers and that fixed number of graphite
layers is called the stage with all the
other host materials the staging
phenomenon is not a very well
established periodicity but in the case
of graphite it is a well-established
periodicity and it allows us to do some
rather sophisticated experiments so
that's the reason we got into the study
of the graphite intercalation compounds
now a one way of thinking about this and
for the next few minutes I will focus on
the simple property that you could think
of the intercalation compound in a
superposition principle we often think
in electromagnetic theory we use the
superposition principle for many things
but also in material science we often
have occasions where we have
superposition here we have a
superposition of a package consisting of
two graphite layers between which the
intercalate is contained that's one
element that element when it occurs in a
stage one compound or in a stage end
compound has the same separation it's
always the same package the graphite
layers themselves retain the same
in-plane spacing and the same spacing
between layers so we could think of that
as the second element and all we're
doing is playing building blocks we take
this this package and the graphite
layers and we stack different amounts of
each together depending on the stage so
in that sense the intercalation
compounds are very simple how oh I don't
have a view graph how they're prepared I
should have taken one along obviously I
should have
well there are many ways to do this the
simplest way is vapor transport where
you take the inter Klint in one part of
an ampule and you have the graphite and
in another part of the ampule and then
you maintain a small temperature
difference with the graphite at a
slightly higher temperature and voila
the
gas-phase seeps into the region where
the graph ideas penetrates between the
layers and then you have the
intercalation compounds by the vapor
pressure and the temperature difference
which is another way of saying the same
thing
well the are in road into the
intercalation business was as I said
through the magneto reflection
experiment that's that's what we really
started out to do back with Ted jabal
back in 1965 that's what we had been
talking about but it took a long time to
do this
well the magneto reflection experiment
yes I really should say I said before
that I had become well known for my work
in in graphite but it wasn't only that I
became known about it for scientific
reasons I also became known about this
before sociological reasons and this
makes too good a story to not to tell an
occasion like this so let me just tell
how I caused the blackout of 1965 I
think that's how Ted jabal really found
out about me more than the science it so
happened and on November 9th at about
5:00 p.m. I was running an experiment at
the magnet lab and I was the only one
there me and the operators and just
about the time that we were at peak
field - we had two generators running at
the same at that at the time we're at
the peak field and watching these
oscillations coming in we were working
on graphite and the oscillations were
coming in and all of a sudden the
oscillations started going wild and the
recorder pen that showed the magnetic
field started going wild from zero all
the way to well we must have been at
that time about 12 13 Tesla going wildly
back between up down between zero and
and 12 or 13 Tesla well we had been
instructed when we at the magnet lab I'd
been working at the magnet lab already
about five years at that time and I knew
when one disaster like that came
to do with touch the throw the panic
button I had never done this before but
this seemed like the right time to do it
so I threw the panic button and I left
the room you know I didn't want this
thing to blow up on me I went out
outside and the lights were dimming and
dimming first they were flickering and
then all of a sudden they went out by
the time I got to the control room at
the magnet lab the whole place was in
utter darkness I said see what I had
done I was the only one running the
experiment it could could only have been
me and I looked outside after a whole
magnet lab was in darkness I looked out
on the street and it wasn't a street
light on either and I said look what
I've done to Cambridge I had been using
10% of the power of Cambridge and I put
Cambridge in the state of darkness well
as you know we had a very big blackout
in 1965 on November 9th that remained
every we would remain without power for
about a day and I'm told that the birth
rate went up noticeably nine months
later anyhow this was a sort of a
precursor of the magneto reflection
experiments on the intercalation
compounds and the first set of
experiments that we ran were gave us
results that we couldn't believe and we
tried these experiments many times
always getting the same results
basically that an intercalation compound
had essentially the same magnetic energy
levels spectrum as graphite you could
see here the identification of the
various magnetic transitions there
hardly hardly changed and here's a plot
of the resonances photon energy versus
magnetic field we did these experiments
many materials many ways we always got
the same results and we didn't believe
it and the public didn't believe it
either and it wasn't for this reason
that we started looking at other aspects
of intercalation and the first thing
that we looked after the magneto
reflection was the phonon modes phonon
modes are significantly different from
electron modes so we if we see nothing
in the electrons maybe we should see
something in the phonons so this seemed
like a totally unrelated experiment
see if we see anything in this case that
tells us that we've intercalated well
the here again we got results that were
kind of also slightly unbelievable the
effect of intercalation on the prophetic
modes was very very small here were at
about 1600 wave numbers here's the odd
graphite line the this mode e to g-tube
mode and it hardly changed as we added
in Terkel and went up in stage however
there was some evidence that that
intercalation did something and that we
had a second ROM on line that was up
shifted by about 20 wave numbers and
this line increased in intensity as the
stage index decrease that is the
concentration increase then finally at
stage two this first line disappeared
and also for stage 1 well the
explanation of this we came up with an
explanation for this pretty soon and the
explanation is we had a bunch of
graphite layers here that they were very
strongly screened from the intercalated
bounding layer and when you get to stage
2 all the let all the graphite layers of
graphite bounding layers there are no
graphite interior layers that are like
the graphite the graphically layers that
are just like the graphite give a
resonance at the same frequency that the
graphite does but the ones that are on
the bounding layer they have a lot more
charge and they will give an upshift
'add mode so that that whole story made
sense even though the effects were
minuscule we learned some science from
this but we also learned from this
something about ethics from this
experience I got a commitment that we
have to teach the cheese students our
graduate students about the ethics of
yeah it's like it's like teaching your
own children about the ethics of how to
how to live teaching your students about
the ethics of science when we did these
experiments and
and presented them at the ApS meeting
right shortly after we had done the
experiments there was another group it
turned out that we're doing similar
experiments and when we presented our
results they said our results were
totally wrong that they had done the
same experiments and found large changes
in the Raman effect and well the large
changes were well accepted by the
community because it had been known that
intercalation changes the electronic
properties by organism magnitude so we
everybody thought that they were right
and we were wrong so we sat on our
results for a long time we presented the
explanation of our results also at that
time and it was quite surprising when
six months later we still were sitting
on our results that we thought were
wrong we found our competition in print
with our proposed explanation of the
effect what that tells you is that
there's epochs in science and we have to
have everybody practice ethics now we
went on and studied the stage dependence
of the phonon spectrum and acceptors is
what I showed you in the previous
viewgraph that the frequency goes up as
you go
increase the amount of intercalate
Terkel in concentration decreased the
stage and for donor compounds the
opposite occurs that is when you
increase the concentration the frequency
goes down now this is the one that we
could understand from what had been done
in the literature on measurement of
lattice constants you have a donor
compound charge for them from the alkali
metal goes into the graphite layers it
expands the lattice constants makes the
mode soft and therefore you have a
decrease in phonon frequency very very
understandable if that's the case then
the opposite should happen in the
acceptor compounds that the addition
of aventure : t' should SAP up electrons
should take electrons away from the
graphite layers
therefore the lattice constants should
contract and therefore you should have a
stiffening of the mode and that's what's
observed but the experiments hadn't been
done so what master's thesis was
generated and we showed that the lattice
constant for acceptors and donors
behaved in the opposite way and the
different magnitudes have to do with the
different amounts of charge transfer
this phonon ik problem was a lot of fun
really because it provided some nice
problem sets for solid-state physics and
I noticed a number of people in the
audience my solid-state physics class
and you're familiar with these equations
for coupled phonons in a solid
one-dimensional line the top being for
similar species and the second set of
equations for two species on the line
well in intercalation compound is really
two different species intercalate and
and graphite layers each layer
represented by one ball and when you use
that model you get very nice phonon
dispersion relations and just fitting
these you get the constants for the the
forces so the phonon dispersion
relations provided a nice set of
examples for the solid state course now
how do we understand the experiments in
transport I said that intercalation
changes the transport properties by an
order of magnitude and then I said also
that the electronic structure didn't
change and the lattice mode structure
didn't change so what changed well what
change was the position of the Fermi
energy I guess the students in a solid
state class have heard me say this very
much very often that you can change the
properties of a solid greatly by change
in the Fermi level keeping the structure
electronic structure the same well how
does that work well here we have the
Internet's the brown positively charged
sitting on the intercalate layer and if
it's an alkali metal each potassium atom
will donate one electron the electron
will go into the graphite layers here
but most of the charge will go into the
graphite bounding layers which are right
next to the intercalary an electrostatic
attraction between the two so we'll get
develop a very heart large carrier
concentration in the graphite bounding
layers very large compared to the
carrier concentration in graphite itself
which has almost no carriers ten to the
minus four electrons per atom at room
temperature and less than that at low
temperature so intercalation allows the
change in the carrier concentration by
approximately three orders of magnitude
so in that way it's possible to greatly
change the transport properties of
intercalation compounds now the reason
why this whole thing works so well is
that the carriers are taken from regions
where they have low mobility for example
a metal normal like copper normally has
a very low mobility 35 centimeter square
per volt second is a small number
compared to 13,000 which is
characteristic of graphite so if you can
take the carriers from a low mobility
region and promote them into a high
mobility region you can really benefit
from that high mobility and that's why
an intercalation compound does have a
high doesn't have a whole lot of
carriers but it has a high conductivity
in fact it is said and some some people
claim they can make compounds that are
have conductivity is higher than copper
at room temperature so now the reason
that works again with small carrier
concentrations is that each carrier has
a high mobility and exactly the same
concept is used in modulation doping of
semiconductors super lattices where you
have a wide gap a semiconductor which
you dope and the electrons will be
transferred into these lower energy
states into the low gap semiconductor
gallium arsenite where there are no
impurities there no scattering centers
so that you have the
carriers and you have the high mobility
and you get high conductivity in that
way well we could also understand from
this model not much intelligence needed
that the dominant important layers in
graphite as far as transport are
concerned or the graphite bounding
layers and to maximize the conductivity
you want the largest fraction of the
sandwich to be graphite bounding layers
that tells you you want to make a low
stage compound but don't make it too
small because if you make it too small
then a large fraction of the sample will
be taken up with intercalate layers
which don't contribute very much to
conductivity and just to remind you that
what I said here is the prophetic layers
just sewn folded to make the different
stages and all that that we're doing
here is we're changing the position of
the Fermi level as we go along and that
makes the difference between stage 1
stage 2 etc for the different
conductivity well by the time we had
done this work I think that our view was
finally accepted by the community it
took several years the early days it was
almost impossible to get any funding to
work on intercalation compounds and when
I I must say that my earliest work on
the intercalation compounds came about
through the courtesy of the Rockefeller
family in 1973 I was appointed for the
first time the Abbey Rockefeller mosaic
professor and that can carried with it a
small stipend I tried hard to get some
money to do intercalation compounds from
the federal agencies but having a
physics background the referee's always
rejected my proposals this work was good
for chemists but not for physicists so
it took a little while before any
funding came about
about four years later when people in
other laboratories show that you could
get big enhancements in conductivity of
like a graphite by intercalation the
funding agencies all of a sudden became
quite excited and it was about that time
that I work that about the explanation
for transport in a system where the
graffiti clay errs were essentially
unchanged from the host material when
everything seemed to come together at
one time and we got going and at that
point we started developing a broader
view of the intercalation compounds a
layered structure is a one-dimensional
and a 2-dimensional thing perpendicular
to the layers which is all that I said
up to this point we have one dimensional
physics and in the layer plains we have
two dimensional physics the two
dimensional physics is seen and look and
study the intercourse
of playing around with the graphite what
the inter colon did to the graphite we
started looking at what graphite does to
be inter Clint turn the problem around
and there were rather interesting things
that happen and I'll be pretty brief
with with what I have to say the first
thing is that you can have different
kinds of structures three basic
different kinds of structures one is
commensurate mention what that is
another incommensurate and thirdly dis
commensurate all of these things occur
in the intercalation compounds as they
do also in interfaces that are grown
stable by molecular beam epitaxy and
I'll have something to say about how
these these different kinds of materials
interrelate
well here is a commensurate structure of
potassium on graphite it forms a
two-by-two
super lattice in-plane two-by-two
meaning that the unit cell this way is
twice the length of the unit cell of the
graphite itself now why does it form a
commensurate lettuce there were two four
is that our important one yes that the
the potassium or the intercalate in
general likes to assume a near neighbor
distance that's almost the same as is in
its native material it's a
two-dimensional material and the
potential minimum for the attraction of
the of the atoms is almost unchanged
from what it is in the host in the
pristine material however we have one
modulation feature and that's the
graphite which makes the inter-clan want
to sit over the hollow of the honeycomb
structure of the graphite lattice
because by doing so we can pack the
three-dimensional crystal and make a
closer packing than any other way so
just by these geometrical arguments you
could see that there are two things
acting one is the inter atomic forces
and the other is the attraction to the
graphite honeycomb lattice and in this
case with very small space Beach from
the closest packing of the interpolate
we can achieve a registry with the
graphite so it likes to do that and in
fact does so in a stage one compound and
to prove that we have that you do a
diffraction pattern and that's a pretty
diffraction pen and I had to draw it for
you to show you the diffraction pattern
for two by two super lattice now what we
see here also occurs in molecular beam
epitaxy when you make a strain layer
super super lattice it's exactly the
same concept we have a material with one
lattice constant another material with
another lattice constant and when you
put very thin layers together the
material with the small lattice constant
will stretch and the material with the
large lattice constant will contract so
that they form together a system with
some kind of compromised lattice
constant which you can control with the
graded layer that you put as the
substrate now
this strain layers super lattice of
course has big impact on semiconductor
technology because in the early days of
molecular beam epitaxy it was thought
that you had to have lattice matching
between the wide gap and there
you have semiconductors that you put
together but the strain layer super
lattice of course you have a great deal
of flexibility because they'll be some
stretching and stretch and give and you
can make almost any material go with
almost any other material and that's
greatly expanded our horizons in the
super lattice field now in the getting
back to the intercalation compounds
another possibility when the nearest
neighbor distances are totally unmatched
to the graphite substrate then they
don't pay any attention to the graphite
substrate at all and they just do their
own thing and they form layers that are
just like layers and the host material
here we see cobalt chloride and graphite
so here's a graphite layer he is a
cobalt chloride try layer sandwich where
the lattice constants of the cobalt
chloride are exactly the same as they
are a native cobalt chloride but there's
there are several differences between
this and what happens in molecular beam
epitaxy for one thing the there's an
orientational locking of the
interconnect to the graphite that is the
graphite the inter : doesn't go in any
which way but it has some preferred
directions where it can stay away from
the graphite layer in a maximal sense
the other thing that happens that's
different from molecular beam epitaxy is
you have an atomic atomically sharp
interfaces just to show you how things
are in molecular beam epitaxy here's the
case for the semiconductors
so here's silicon and here's our nickel
silicide now that forms a very nice
commensurate structure very much like
potassium on graphite but here's the
situation of an incommensurate structure
of germanium with very and fluoride
where the lattice constants are
sufficiently different that you don't
form a nice interface and the interface
is mushy and and corresponds to several
atomic distances however for
intermediate cases where the lattice
constants don't differ by that much you
have you can form something that's
called a dis commensurate phase where
locally you get phase matching you have
good registry between the two materials
but because the lattice constant here is
at least smaller than the lattice
constant up in here you have to have
extra planes and the extra planes are
what's called this commence rationed now
sometimes these Disco mentions are forum
periodic structures all in themselves
and when that happens it's called the
stripe domain phase and I'll say
something about that we stumbled on this
whole thing whole field in a very
unexpected way shortly after we got into
while looking at phonon spectrum
intercalation compounds we found that
out that in the bromine system you could
look both at the graphite modes and at
the intercalate modes separately and
what that meant was that we could
monitor say phase transitions looking at
what happened in the in the bromine
layer and at the same time we could look
independently and what happened in the
host layer and then by changing the
temperature the ideas that we could see
something associated with melting we
were really looking for melting of the
bromine layers so here's a Raman
spectrum of the bromine stretch mode in
bromine intercalation compound and it's
a nice Lorenz eonline for a while and
then the line shaped seems to change and
we go all of a sudden it disappears and
the disappearance of the line
corresponds to a melting transition but
before it melted we had a line change
Why should there be a line change shape
change in line shape we at room
temperature line shape is Lorenzen which
i indicates that you have a homogeneous
lee broaden line but then when the
temperature went up just by a few
degrees 345 degrees for example
no more Lorenzi in line shape but
gaussian line shape which indicates in
homogeneous broadening now what could
have caused that well from the Raman
spectrum there would be no way to
decipher that so we went to our good
friend Bob Birgeneau
and asked if he would like to do some
structural work and see if there was
something funny that happened in the
bromine system and in so doing we came
upon the Striped domain phase I'd say a
little bit about this what the stripe
domain phase allows us to do is to take
the bromine layer and allow its lattice
constant to increase above that which
would be which which it would have it
was commensurate with the graphite on a
macroscopic scale while at the same time
locally there would be a commensurate
register register between the bromine
layers and the graphite and now that's
done by having a domain within this
domain we have a commensurate phase and
then there's a wall where the bromine is
more is more dilute less dense so that
the average lest that lattice constant
then will be larger and by having the
number of unit cells capital n decrease
as the temperature is increased then the
average lattice constant of bromine
could grow so that was the idea of this
that's the idea of the striped domain
phase the physical basis of why it
occurs in graphite is that graphite has
essentially no lattice expansion
whatsoever and anything that you put in
any intercalate will have a normal
lattice expansion so it will grow and as
it grows it wants to accommodate itself
to a larger lattice constant it stays
commensurate for a while but afterwards
it decides that this is no fun and it
goes into this striped domain face now
the evidence for for this comes from
some very beautiful work that was done
in bird nose group here's the crystal
structure here's the bromine molecules
registered are graphite this is the room
temperature commensurate phase for
bromine molecules per unit cell in the
direction of this large part of the unit
cells seven times the graphite lattice
constant that's the direction in which
the Striped domain phase gets
established here at here are the
diffraction spots as shown schematically
the triangles correspond to the graphite
spots so between these two
graphite spots we divide the unit into
seven equal parts and we put spots these
spots here are the spots of the super
lattice and they're equally spaced for
the case of the commensurate unit cell
but after we go above this temperature
342 degrees where we started seeing this
Gaussian line shape and the Raman
spectrum these spots no longer are in a
division divisible by this distance but
they move in the direction of the arrows
firstly by little amounts but always in
this ratio given by this code now the
fact that they move in this prescribed
manner and they the incommensurability
which is related to the reciprocal of
the subdomain size the fact that that
this incommensurability has a unique
temperature dependence which depends on
the reduced temperature to the one-half
power this and the motion of the spots
are in indication or a signature where
the onset of this of the stripe domain
phase since initiating this work bob has
gone on to do some very elegant work
using synchrotron radiation where he's
followed these transitions in great
detail and has studied the melting
transition and I've always felt happy
that I've introduced him to
intercalation compounds because he's
done some very nice work in fundamental
science of two-dimensional systems as a
result of this introduction the magnetic
phase transitions in intercalation
compounds are also extremely interesting
and the main thing that we'd like what
it have wanted to do in this system is a
goal that still is unaccomplished but
I'm still hoping that in a short time
this goal will be realized and this is
the observation some kind of direct
observation of magnetic vortices in two
dimensional systems now we haven't done
that yet but we have managed to see some
very elegant or very interesting
magnetic phase diagrams many men
magnetic phases and making use of the
high magnetic fields and I thought that
this would be a good tide to give a plug
for the national magnet lab without
whose facilities this work would not
have been possible the system I'd like
to talk about is europium in graphite
and europium is a four F metal that's
magnetic and the spins in murrow pium
will couple rather strongly to the
graphite where the you have a lot of
conduction electrons and depending on
the ordering of the spins in the
europium layers you get different kind
of scattering in the graphite layers so
we could see magnetic phase changes by
MA during by monitoring either the say
the magnetization that's one thing but
what I'm going to show you for about
here are results on conductivity
measurements and this turned out to be a
very sensitive and kind of a fun
experiment it's kind of nice for this
kind of presentation to hopefully some
non experts in the audience as well as
experts here we have transport
properties resistivity as a function of
magnetic field and you see glitches you
see big changes occurring as a function
of magnetic field
each of these glitches I put a little
red dot I chose a magnetic phase
transition and there they make this one
here in particular this is the c-axis
magnetic field in current directions you
could see that the plot what we're
plotting here is different temperatures
each each scan is taken at a different
temperature and you can almost see the
magnetic phase diagram pop out at you
just by looking at the data the
transport data well taking each of these
temperature sweeps and this is
temperature here and going up in in
temperature just make dots for all of
these things and you develop a magnetic
phase diagram that's so simple enough
but what is the explanation of what the
spins are doing that's a little bit more
difficult and to a stet there were two
things that were done
there was a model calculation done by
da2 in Japan and we did a Monte Carlo
simulation which identified what these
various spend states are and there was a
little bit of new physics that came from
this a little bit unexpected and
magnetism course and basic solid-state
course we always teach that the
Heisenberg Hamiltonian that that
controls the magnetic interaction and in
a magnetic system is a quadratic form
between adjacent spins and then we go
second neighbors third neighbors etc but
with a Hamiltonian like that you get
nowhere with this phase diagram you need
to have some higher order terms these by
quadratic terms and for ring spin terms
that show up in a triangular lattice
these things had been predicted but
there had been no real observations but
for this system in order to get the
ferromagnetic phase the one with the two
spins up and one spin down it's
necessary to have the terms in the blue
and the red and that was a new piece of
physics the reason they're so big is
because we have spent 1/2 europium you
know as a half-filled shell and that
makes it kind of interesting I should
point out and and and remark that these
experiments were made use of the highest
fields available we went up to the
maximum we use the hybrid magnet for
these experiments and it was a kind of a
new experience we enjoyed that very much
well super conductivity is where we
started with the intercalation compounds
and that's where I'm going to finish
with the intercalation compounds that we
have full circuit and the bottom line
about super conductivity and
intercalation compounds is that in
intercalation or the layering process
enhances super conductivity now we have
two pieces of evidence for this that are
compelling to me one is that you can
make something superconducting where the
constituents are neither are super
conducting and that's the case of the
alkali metals and here's an example of
chk stage 1 potassium in graphite and
that has
oh pretty low transition temperature but
still in all potassium isn't
superconducting nor is is carbon now
when you take something that is
superconducting like potassium mercury
that's an interesting system it has a
transition temperature of about one
degree Kelvin you put it in an
intercalation compounds that of one
degree you get one and a half degrees so
for its systems that are not
superconducting you can make them
superconducting and systems that have a
low transition temperature you can
enhance it so that's an interesting
point so super conductivity and
intercalation compounds is something
that is worth trying to understand
however there are things about it that
are unexpected this is an anisotropic
system and you're quite prepared that
the critical field will be anisotropic
it should be however and there's a
theory for Ana and ice and ice ah droopy
and critical field mean field theory and
it gives a prediction for what the
angular dependence of the critical field
should be in terms of a parameter HC 2
which is for parallel the theta equals
zero when the field is along the C axis
and HC 2 perpendicular when it's at
right angles and the problem is that in
the intercalation compounds the ratio of
these quantities HC 2 para perpendicular
to parallel is not independent of
temperature it's supposed to be a
dependent temperature but it but it
isn't experimental II it's found not to
be also the temperature dependence of HC
2 doesn't follow this mean field value
this mean field curves predicts that HC
2 should go in linearly to have a linear
dependence on 1 minus TT is the reduced
temperature close to the critical
temperature but by the time you're about
six tenths of equal to t little T equal
to 6/10 you should start seeing
significant deviations from
linear dependence so in these two
respects the intercalation compounds
show significant departures and here's
some evidence this is Allison Jenkins
PhD thesis or the beginnings of it and
here's a plot know of hc2 versus angle
for a temperature close to the critical
temperature and this ratio here is 8
then when you get closer to the t equals
0 the reduced temperature 0.3 then this
ratio turns out to be significantly
larger unexpected from a mean field
theory model for anisotropic
superconductors the temperature
dependence of the critical field is
supposed to go like this it's supposed
to have saturated at low temperatures
but for as low in temperatures we've
gone so far it seems to be linear data
is kind of noisy but we're still going
way lower than what you would expect for
a linear dependence so right now we're
headed in two directions going to higher
stages to look for more anteye anteye
saw trippy effects and hopefully to get
into the region where the coherence
distance will become less than a lattice
constant in that regime we should have
something approaching two-dimensional
super conductivity where we expect
rather different behavior than what we
have in the region here where the
coherence distance is large compared to
the repeat distance in the unit cell now
this field has become of course very
interesting very recently because of the
discovery of the high temperature
superconductors which of course are
layered compounds and have some
similarity to intercalation compounds
because we have copper oxide layers here
and copper oxide layers here and then we
have spacer layers the spacer layers are
different things for different compounds
I've shown here a picture of a lanthanum
barium series because I know what the
crystal straw
sure is for that one for the the the 98
degree one I I've seen different crystal
structures and I'm not exactly sure
people don't exactly agree on what the
crystal structures are but what they all
agree on is that there are spacer layers
well the spacer layers are a lot like
intercalation compounds because here we
have conduction electrons that's the
graphite and here we have something else
and what is the connection I don't know
but there are other people think that
think that there's some connection here
because when Allison was talking about
this at the APS meeting at the
intercalation session when hurt just
before her talk started they had a room
that was about like this a lot of empty
seats and then when her talk was about
to start people came into the door and
when her talk was going on place was
halfway well what's quite filled and as
soon as her talk was over half the
audience got up and left again so there
are people out there that think that
intercalation compounds might have
something to do with the layered
layering business in the high TC
superconductors well from a pedagogical
point of view I think that the advent of
high TC superconductors a great boon for
people in materials research so many of
the big discoveries in the last decade
or so have been inaccessible to students
when MBE came in everybody knew this was
very important but almost nobody had the
finances either the money to buy the
systems or the technical support staff
to do it when the scanning tunneling
microscope came it seemed like like that
also would need some very very special
engineering to make that go of course a
short time we found out that that was
accessible and now we have scanning
toing microscopes all over the place but
but many fields of science are quite
inaccessible to university people
because of the cost but what this thing
is different because most anybody seems
to be able to make samples there are
samples all over the place and there are
all kinds of measurements that are
interesting and exciting so this seems
like a good field to get students I
sited about da solid-state physics of
course you know that there were a
hundred other people out there doing the
same experiments you better be doing
something else for your thesis work but
I you can participate in the excitement
for a while and that's a lot of fun now
here's a change of area but to me it's
just a continuum there are very many
things that we would like to make many
kinds of intercalation compounds that
we'd like to make but we don't know how
to synthesize them if we could just put
in any old any arbitrary metal in
graphite or say with these high TC
superconductors we can just stuff in a
copper oxide layer if we know how to do
any of these things and put them between
graphite layers we could really do some
very exciting science and some years ago
I had the idea that if we implanted in
the Terkel graphite with something and
then subsequently intercalated that we
would it might have some chance of
getting things in that wouldn't go by
themselves why would that be well if you
implant something you know that it with
an ion implanter you can plant any any
element in the periodic table so once
you get get these elements between
graphite layers it opens up the graphite
layers and then once the graphite layers
are opened up then subsequent addition
of an inter colon species should be easy
well we tried this idea and it sort of
works but I think this technology will
take a lot of doing and we haven't
pursued it to the extent that we should
now the idea is so we intercalate
graphite with some species that either
doesn't intercalate at all or
intercalates poorly so here's a test
sample that we've implanted here and
this is a protection aluminum foil so
that there's no going over here and so
we have the reference control specimen
and here's the sample implanted sample
and what what we do then is we take the
sample and put it into our
our ampule and we start an interglacial
and we see if there is an enhanced
intercalation in the region that's been
implanted so we have a control sample oh
well I guess this is the whole thing so
we have the control sample here that was
prepared at the same time the same
intercalation as this one that half of
it was implanted and then we look with
raman spectroscopy on this side we have
a micro probe so we can look very close
to the implanted region and we do get an
enhancement this is the graphite
bounding layer so it shows that we've
made a lower stage compound in this case
for the implanted case and for the other
case well we've tried this a little
further but the results have not been as
encouraging as I would like however I
think that's a good idea I would like to
encourage other people that work on it
we had more time I guess we would do
more on it ourselves last time I talked
about the use of ion implantation too as
a way to study regrowth in anisotropic
materials and I won't bore you with this
again except to say that in so doing we
used annealing as a method of recovery
so we put in the ions and we make this
awful mess we introduce a lot of damage
and then we anneal the sample and we
kneel kneel out the mess and we try to
regrow this system that we started with
and in so doing we measure both the
temperature dependence and the time
dependence the temperature dependence
gives us the activation energy and the
time dependence gives us information on
the kinetics well why we were doing this
we had the idea
gee-whiz instead of using furnaces why
don't we try using laser annealing and
so we tried to try to graphite sample
and
and part of the laser pulse irradiated
the the sample with laser pulse
radiation what the idea that we would
affect something annealing well of
course the opposite happened it didn't
make a kneeling at all but made more
disorder but when we thought about the
disorder we found out that we stumbled
on a very good problem and that is the
laser melting of graphite and that's
what my last topic and I'll just say a
few things about that because I think
that's been one of the most exciting
things that we've been doing with
graphite recently and it ends up with a
big controversy in the field and it's
always nice to end the talk with the
controversy well the idea of the laser
melting I mentioned last time that
graphite has is the highest melting
temperature material in nature it melts
at about 40 450 Kelvin a very high
temperature indeed so you can't put the
graphite in a crucible to melt it
because the crucible will melt before
the graphite so you have to melt the
melt the graphite in its own crucible
so here's graphite and we put a laser
beam in and we're gonna make a little
puddle of graphite inside a graphite
wafer so here's our laser pulse what we
use are 30 nano second pulses of a ruby
laser and the energy is I don't have I
don't even have the photon energy there
the skin depth falls off with a usual
skin depth of a few hundred angstroms
and when it went once we melt the the
graphite then we have the melt
temperature here for a little distance
and here's the melt front and as we
increase the laser energy the melt front
moves into the sample when the laser
pulse is turned off the melt front
recedes goes back to the surface and we
get regrowth so that's basically what
the experiment is that we did and where
do we sit on the graphite phase diagram
here's the graphite phase diagram a very
historical phase diagram the phase
diagram of bundi that has to do with the
formation of diamonds
and so here's the diamond phase that was
what the stock phase diagram was was
concocted for but we're over here at a
very low pressure but high temperature
and we're gonna melt carbon at least we
think we're gonna melt carbon and we did
four different experiments initially to
show that you could make liquid carbon
one of the them is Rutherford
backscattering in the channeling mode
then we put in an implanted markers
Raman scattering and transmission
electron microscopy need none of these
experiments by themselves were
especially convincing that liquid carbon
had been formed but taken altogether
there was no way that we could explain
all the results without the formation
from liquid carbon the collaborators in
this work we had a bunch of MIT people
and three people from Bell Labs
Venkatesh and Jacobsen and Gibson this
experiment would not have been possible
without the collaboration of Bell Labs
and their wonderful facilities and I
wanted to make one philosophical comment
about where I think Materials Research
in the future was going that we'll have
more and more of these kinds of
collaborations because the cost of
equipment is going up and up and
becoming less and less accessible for
university type people on the other side
from the industrial standpoint people in
industry are getting more and more
pushed for fast results at relevance of
their research so they are getting more
interested in having university people
do far-out things so I see this as a
future trend in our field a future trend
and I think maybe a welcome trend I
don't think it's a bad trend at all I
think it's maybe a good trend well here
are the four experiments about melting
carbon this is the PhD thesis of John
Steinbeck the first experiment is rather
for the backscattering channeling if the
helium ions that were
using to probe the carbon they have a
high-energy 2 MeV if they're directed
along the c-axis
then they don't see the ions very
effectively and they'll miss the ions to
some degree and the scattering intensity
the back scattering will be at this low
level here that I've indicated here by
the word channeling however when the
beam is tipped away from the z-axis by
even a fraction of a degree then
there'll be copious scattering of the
carbon atoms and will be up in this
range the random range now if we
introduce disorder in the crystal that
is we don't have a very well-defined C
axis and it's off by a bit then the will
go from this channeling level to the
random level now there's also a depth
dependence that Rutherford
backscattering is sensitive to why is
that the helium atoms that are scattered
from the surface atoms will come back
with the maximum energy but those that
get scattered from a carbon atoms in a
tan interior position will come back
with less energy because they lose
energy coming to the surface so that the
energy of the helium atoms once they
come out of the graphite is an
indication of the depth from which they
were scattered so we have a depth scale
that we show on the top okay that's all
the background that you need to
understand the experiment now we zap the
graphite with a laser at different
levels and here are the different levels
and it's key coded on on the curves
initially we stay at the channeling
direction but as the laser energy
increases this level we get some
disorder scattering and the disorder
scattering increases as the laser
intensity increases and it increases in
increases here by the time we're 1.2
joules per square centimeter
we have a sharp interface and we get
almost a random situation at the surface
that's sharp interface moves as we go
inside the crystal the sharp in
interface suggested
that we had melting but we didn't really
believe it so we tried the next
experiment which is a marker now here's
a marker of arsenic we're still gonna do
Rutherford backscattering but now we'll
do back scattering from the arsenic
atoms arsenic being heavier than carbon
will deliver a back scattered helium
atoms and a much higher energy so that's
separated from the energy that we get
from the scattering of the carbon atoms
when the laser energy is is zero or very
small we get this profile from the
Rutherford backscattering as a laser
energy increases you could think of the
melt front moving in from the surface
inside the Carbon region still far from
the arsenic implant so when we're over
here we still retain essentially the
same arsenic line but as the melt front
approaches that of the arsenic the
arsenic joins in the puddle and
segregates the surface and we see that
effect here much of the arsenic leaves
as it melts and and the rest begins to
segregate to the surface so all that
experiment is highly suggestive of
having molten carbon the Raman
experiments similarly can be explained
in terms of melting carbon and so here's
a 0 before we start the laser
irradiation and after some laser
irradiation we in addition to the Raman
allowed line we get a disorder induced
line and the line widths get kind of
broad indicating we have a rather
disordered system but as the laser
energy density increases instead of
getting more disorder we get less
disorder the lines sharpen up and we get
a spectrum that's closer to that of the
graphite well that's explained here in
this little picture where initially we
make little tiny the material is molten
for a very very small time the rapid
solidification forms very small little
crystal lights and the little Chris
lights are - all random directions so
you get a rather disordered system but
it
if the molten region is allowed to stay
molten for a longer period of time
the little crystallites grow and in fact
some fraction of these crystallites
might be oriented normal to the original
crystallites so we get some interesting
results from that
so the raman scattering experiment also
favors not compelling but it's hard to
explain it by any other means than we
formed molten carbon the transition
transmission electron microscopy
experiments likewise can be explained in
terms of the melting of carbon because
for the high laser energy densities we
form a ring at the 0:02 position
indicating that we form crystallites at
right angles to the direction of the
original carbon how could that that form
if we didn't have molten carbon so
that's a fairly conclusive evidence that
we formed molten carbon now to explain
the depth of disorder quantitatively as
a function of the amount of laser energy
put into the system john steinbeck has
formed a model he solved the diffusion
equation the heat equation with a
driving term having to do with the laser
energy that that's put in and you have
to take a lot of defects into into
account it's not only melting but it's
also vaporization of the surface because
the vaporization point of carbon is very
close to the melting point and when all
in all of this is done we took two
limits into consideration one is that
the liquid carbon is a Xiamen liquid
having four electrons per atom so that's
a metallic form of carbon and another
form was in a semi insulating form where
the constants of the liquid form were
just like that of the solid extrapolated
continuously across the phase transition
well the it's clear that the metallic
carbon fits the results a whole lot
better than the solid extension model
which is that of an
so later however we're not the only
people that are working in this field
when we came up with these results some
of our competitors up the river who are
doing experiments like this in the
picosecond range believe firmly that
liquid carbon is insulating in the
interim we've both done a series of
experiments our experiments seem to say
that liquid carbon is metallic their
experiments seem to say that liquid
carbon is insulating well two groups
with different results is interesting
and that of course attracts a few people
into the for a so now there are six
groups that are working in this and the
score is pretty much even we have
ourselves with the bell people we these
are the metallic types the Bundy from GE
the man that made diamonds to begin with
he made liquid carbon also and he thinks
it's conducting and the GM people have
recently done in experiments and wires
they think it's it's conducting also but
the Harvard people have been joined by
the los alamos a group at los alamos and
a group of by at maryland and so we have
three three again three half think that
it's conducting half think that it's
insulating well life is always
interesting when there's a controversy
and this is a friendly controversy we
all talk to each other we all help each
other but we don't really know what the
answer is
now the coward's way out is to look at
the phase diagrams and here are a whole
bunch of phase diagrams for carbon and
this gives you an idea what a mess the
field is in these are all pretty recent
most of them are pretty recent and
they're all very different and if you
look at them you see that there are some
people that predict metallic liquid and
there's some people that have an
insulating liquid and then they have
even two kinds of liquids so what what a
cowardly way out is to say that they're
really to liquid carbons
conducting and insulating one but I
think that that none of the six groups
working in the field really believe this
I think down deep we feel that there's
only one kind of liquid carbon and the
range that we're all looking at and and
we're not really sure whether it's
conducting or insulating well these are
some adventures in the field of carbon
science and you see that that the not
not the whole story is told there's
still many untold stories that will keep
generations of students busy when a
student turns in a PhD thesis at MIT
there are two things that we look for I
think a philosophical sense that the
student has broken new ground that this
is something new field new area is
something that's totally different from
what went before and if it's so it
usually leads to more work than we
started and that's what keeps science
going forward
[Applause]
questions yes is it possible to laser a
Neil Diamond yes yes it does
it converts it actually converts it into
a mixed phase that experiment was done a
few months after we did our experiment
but it was published in a geological
journal so it took us a while to find
out about each other and it was done by
accident it was done under high pressure
in a diamond anvil cell and they they
zapped the sample inside the diamond
anvil cell and they melted the carbon
and it became graphite and I was unhappy
a thing for the diamond cell but a good
thing for science and they thought that
they had had discovered liquid carbon
for the first time so they were very
excited about it
well diamond has some small impurities
diamond it's very difficult to make
diamond without any impurities now
actually a diamond doesn't have enough
impurities for our taste because we're
trying to do these experiments by
implanting impurities into diamond to
make it door being enough to do some
melting experiments so - for art 'likes
we would like it to be more absorbing
but but diamond does have native
impurities that do absorb some light and
that's what did it the way I what you
would think that the diamonds I use for
anvil cells would be pretty good
actually because that you want to add
them to be strong but they still will
absorb to some degree I mean these are
pretty intense laser beams
in there but what I think in this
process
yes obviously the layers are going to be
straight and if they if the layers get
thick enough then you can't make the
straight layer superlattice people have
I don't know that anybody has done a
Raman experiment because I guess the
strain isn't totally uniform through the
entire layer although the layer has to
the lattice constant has to be preserved
otherwise the whole thing would crack so
I think the I guess the whole thing
would be under some kind of intense
strain the thicker the layer gets I
don't know that anybody has done Raman
scattering from the strain layer super
lattice but I would imagine that that's
a certainly a doable experiment
experiment probably has been done and
and when one can get a measure of the
force constant but as long as a thing
stays together
then you're just going to measure the
force constant for the equilibrium
situation so that's hardly what you're
looking for
that's right there's a tension at the
interface layer but it does stay
together well however I'm told that that
in time if you if you keep these string
layers super lattices around for a year
or ten years for some length of time a
long time then then they they come apart
they don't have a long term stability
but maybe maybe the ones that have been
made more recent times do stay together
the you know that the Straight layer of
super lattice has it old history that
the first few years of the strain layer
super lattice it didn't work at all
this is fellow at IBM was doing it and
nobody paid much attention to him and
but he not only did it but he worked out
the theory for it and and the credit has
gone to other people who made it work
more more effectively later on yes
yes that's an interesting thing and a
little difficult to do on the earth but
maybe in Astrophysical entities that
that's a possibility you know that that
liquid carbon is is something since we
gotten into the field we found out that
this is a topic of great interest to
astrophysicists and to geologists and
all kinds of people that are not
solid-state types yeah it's it's not
much above the melting points about
4,700 K so we're very close it's very
different from the other group for
semiconductors
well Carbon considered thinking of it as
a group for material where the
difference between the vapor the boiling
point and the melting point is many know
long a very large temperature difference
but in this case it's very close makes
the properties of liquid carbon kind of
interesting well I think we're finished
in
[Applause]